Esta es la imagen de muchos hospitales
en Sudán los saqueos bombardeos y la
escasez de medicinas agua y electricidad
dificultan la atención médica de los
heridos en las hostilidades que
iniciaron el pasado 15 de abril en
jartum la capital sólo el 16% de los
hospitales están en funcionamiento Según
la OMS y el resto ha tenido que
suspender sus actividades por los
ataques generando también una estampida
del personal sanitario los trabajadores
de la salud de Sudán han estado haciendo
lo imposible atender a los heridos sin
agua electricidad ni suministros médicos
básicos el sistema de salud sudanés ya
era deficiente antes del conflicto y
ahora se encuentra al borde del colapso
a medida que los cadáveres acumulan en
las calles las personas mueren en sus
hogares por falta de atención médica
básica la OMS señaló que las
organizaciones humanitarias están
huyendo Pese a que un tercio de la
población sudanesa ya dependía de las
ayudas humanitarias para sobrevivir
incluso antes de esta crisis se sabe que
el sistema de salud en Sudán pasó por
años difíciles que hicieron que su
infraestructura fuera frágil y débil
esto incluye hospitales y centros de
salud de diferentes niveles en Sudán
una situación crítica para los más
vulnerables unos cuatro millones de
mujeres enfermas o embarazadas y 50.000
niños que padecen desnutrición aguda el
domingo llegaron a Puerto Sudán 8
toneladas de suministros médicos vitales
ahora la problemática está en Cómo
transportar estos insumos a las zonas
más damnificadas en medio de los
combates